[Music]
today is the day football fans around
the world have been waiting for when the
nfl debuts its 2022 season schedule our
friend bill cower from the nfl today
gave us a little preview earlier this
week revealing the denver broncos los
angeles rams matchup on christmas day
which will be a good one right here on
cbs but how exactly does the league
determine the full schedule when there
seems to be an endless combination of
opponents venues dates and bye weeks
earlier this week we took a trip to the
nfl offices here in new york city to
meet a very small but very vital team of
gridiron matchmakers
[Applause]
if you ever wondered how your favorite
team landed in snowy buffalo in december
this is just a wild scene in buffalo or
how the league somehow predicted that
perfect late season matchup here goes
you are not alone he hurdles and picks
up the first down
whoa the answers it turns out are far
more complicated than just sheer luck i
wonder how much of this
is still pretty much intact inside this
cramped room on manhattan's east side
mike north charlotte carey and ani bose
have been huddling for months you're
right i think we put new england mini in
there day one it may look like a college
freshman's dorm room but it has the feel
of something else altogether experience
north has been working this room for the
past quarter century and not too long
ago no computers no artificial
intelligence this was all done by hand
one game at a time yeah the miracle
isn't so much that we get through
hundreds of thousands of contenders
schedules today it's that we ever got
one done
by hand
it is truly remarkable every one of
these games can go in any one of now 18
weeks any one of seven networks any one
of ten different times you could put it
on sunday night you could put it on
monday night you can put it on sunday
afternoon you can put it in germany you
can put it on thanksgiving you can put
it on christmas you put in the first
half of the season you put in the second
half of the season
do that calculation for each of these
272 assets and you find real quickly
that you knew the computers were going
to do an infinitely better job than the
humans ever could doing it one game at a
time so let's break it down the league
has 32 teams each team plays 17 regular
season games
for a total of 272 contests
some in london this year a game in
germany one in mexico
then factor in weather travel distances
bye weeks broadcast partner needs
and scheduled stadium events so when i
walked in here i was expecting
it to look like an episode of homeland
we're talking focus points charts and
targets yarn strung together on faces of
different players and coaches
how do you not overload doing this job
it's long days and long nights and a
really long few months day after super
bowl we pretty much you know kind of
close and lock the door in here and
that's when we get started then go
through draft and uh then you know two
weeks later or so we put our schedule up
we we give the commissioner our best
schedule honestly we're not even done
yet nate so what it's still working
still it's still in progress broncos at
the rams christmas day yep the rams
coming off a super bowl matthew stafford
at quarterback russell wilson new bronco
that sounds like a football game those
are the games that are going to get the
most viewers and the most eyeballs and
you want to put them into the biggest
windows and spread them across all of
our partners so whether it's sunday
afternoon at 4 25 or monday night or
thursday night
you want to find that balance and then
in between all of that the the math is
the computers filling out the rest
the team told me they used thousands of
cloud-based computers to help narrow
down the potential trillions yes that's
right trillions of combinations to just
one single working schedule
it's so
incredible like the ramifications of
what happens in that room right people
plan birthday parties they plan parties
at their house they plan trips like when
that lands because of the work you just
showed lives change it's so true we're
talking bachelor parties weddings i mean
getaways they planted around the
football season and not to mention you
still have to make the players happy i
remember
and i didn't care about who we played or
if we were on prime time you were just
glad to play i was just glad to play and
i wanted warm weather games in the month
of december and january but other guys
they all had issues with certain parts
of the scheduling process which i did
not know i learned a lot because they
want prime time i like mr manbun what's
his name mike
mike mike i like you mike
has a new nickname he will no longer be
known as mike around his his man bun is
tight looks good but but the way all the
planning that goes into it and the way
he sort of laid it all out for you i
thought was really fascinating is i knew
they planned it but i had no idea it was
that detail they said imagine the
largest rubik's cube in your hand and
trying to figure it out all right that's
what it is all right the full 2022 nfl
schedule will be revealed tonight at 8
pm eastern on the nfl network and
paramount plus